rolled that I'm still great friends with
the guy and I'm not just saying that
cause he's sitting to my left he is also
the man who hosts the show in front of
this one every single day on audience
and hopefully on every radio station
America from 9:00 to noon he is Dan
Patrick the host of undeniable with Dan
Patrick is will haunt audience good to
see you sir good to see you again did I
miss anything that's that's quite a list
right there that I've got of your oh
there's some Emmys in there some awards
I got like that no no I'm good are you
aware we learned this last night from
Mike del Teufel I don't know if you were
there for this sort of crazy can you you
say you can regaled you can get the Emmy
reconditioned are you aware of that you
know that if you're at me home it's it's
beginning to fray a little bit tarnish
yeah if you wanna Sh oh no I don't I
don't want it I want it to look like
it's been used yeah it's you know it's
got some wear and tear did you do it did
you treat yours like the Stanley Cup
like you took it around it did a tour no
the first Emmy I got and you know you
know she has wings and so my son thought
it would be funny if we used it and put
hot dogs on the point of her wings and
then grilled with it like just as a
photo-op
like not have the grill on but that it
would be funny and and I'm glad I didn't
because the the Sports Emmy people don't
you know they don't like that you know
they don't they don't think that's funny
and so I'm glad that I didn't do it but
I did think about that and then I ran it
by somebody when he sports Emmys and
they said that's not a good idea and I
thought maybe it would prevent me from
winning other sports enemies is that
right yeah that you'd be on some sort of
list but I also got Darius Rucker gave
me his Grammy
when Hootie the Blowfish won in
1994-1995 and I said look you got
Grammys like just give me one so he gave
me his Grammy and I put it on my desk
and I had it on my desk for months next
thing I know I get this
anok phone call from Darius Rucker you
gotta send me that that Grammy back and
I said come and get it and he and he
goes no I'm serious I gotta have the
Grammy back the Grammy is there the
really upset that I loaned that out to
you yeah so I had to overnight it pack
it up the whole thing and send it down
to him
because he was dead serious that he
thought the Grammys were going to hold
it against him that he didn't value the
Grammy that he would give it to some
lowlife like me and put it on my desk
for a sports show was there any part of
you Dan Patrick that thought of crafting
a letter a stern letter not a David
Stern letter but a stern letter and send
it to an authority in in charge of the
Grammys and say Do You Know Who I am
did any people like you're not just
somebody Dan no I have such appreciation
for music and and Darius and what he's
done and I would never want to have that
prevent him from winning other grants so
you sent it back - I did
did he did he pay for the pack he did
not there was no co D there was none of
that no but you know he's been such a
great friend and I met him in 1994 I was
at the Masters in Augusta so the band is
there nobody knows who they are they
just started they just launched from
South Carolina yeah I only you know hold
my hand yeah they see me but they don't
come up to me because they don't think
that I know who they are so I never knew
they were there and they said you know
we met you know a couple of years ago
and I go where and they said it the
Masters I guess so they walked by me and
and I didn't know that they were walking
by me and that's the first time that we
met I've been to Darius his wedding
like I've been involved with them for
almost 25 they're coming up on their
25th anniversary there I remember when
you were on the ESPN Radio Network and
there was a roast on your behalf in
Chicago in oil in you hosted and I was a
roast master and I worked very very blue
that night on behalf of the roast they
played it were they not the musical yeah
I'll never forget rick reilly now what
happens in a roast is you don't
necessarily roast the person who's
supposed to be roasted right you start
roasting everybody on the dais yeah
right so rick reilly the great sports
writer gets up and he said hey I want to
thank Darius Rucker for being here I've
got your album Hootie's greatest hit and
you can just see Darius look like wait
what did I do
so Riley making fun that he only they
only had one song hold my hand Ryan
meanwhile they sold seventeen million of
that album and I just remember going
I don't like roasts because it felt like
everybody was getting shot oh well but
that was my job was to be used and I had
to I had to make sure that all the tapes
were destroyed
is there still a tape on I don't know
but I was in a panic so we do this roast
and rich starts out with a line that I
went
there's careers in jeopardy no one speed
when it comes to roasting I mean like
that's what he lured me floored me with
the first line it had to do with Brent
Musburger and I would say draw your own
conclusions but you can't even get to
where rich God with that conclusion oh
my god so the whole night with this
roast I'm thinking I don't know if I'm
gonna have a job when I get home there's
bad and I immediately Paulie my producer
he said Paulie make sure there's no tape
make sure there's no end it's not safe
somewhere in your outer surface well
he's not answering the quad so that the
tape exists it might but but but Rob
Dibble was my co-host former baseball
pitcher nasty boy so he's getting upset
with people who are roasting me he wants
to fight that so he's with me on the
dais he doesn't understand this that I
said it's okay and he is MF and people
he's he's like who wants to fight him I
go no it's called a roast get dibs like
they're supposed to
mean things about you right yeah and I
said even if they're not true they say
mean things about you dan Patrick here
on the Rich Eisen show in Atlanta the
Vince Lombardi Trophy you I'm not gonna
tie know that I know that a tradition
unlike any other got me again dan
Patrick being hearty trophy so several
times you were on the podium for NBC
what was the most Awkward trophy
presentation tation that you had doing
that oh they they all have a moment of
awkwardness that's usually with the
microphone well there's okay you're told
never to give that I'll never give up
the microphone so I have somebody
talking to my ear as I'm handing out the
Super Bowl trophy so they're just trying
to get you to move it along maybe have
four people up there owner coach MVP and
or quarterback and you're supposed to
ask two questions and it move on and the
Giants win the Super Bowl and one of
their owners is grabbing the microphone
and I you can't give up the microphone
so you'll see he's pulling the mic like
this and I'm grabbing it too so we're
we're arm wrestling on a microphone in
front of a hundred million people is how
to be Tisch right yes so Steve Tisch
because they think it's you know it's
their time live at the improv you know
hey I'd like to say a couple of things
and I got a couple of jokes here so I'm
going like this to get it back from him
the other time the Steelers win they
beat the Cardinals
Santonio Holmes has the incredible catch
in the corner of the end zone I'm up on
the podium the commissioners there Joe
Namath is bringing the trophy up I still
don't know who's the MVP
Roethlisberger is up there cuz
Roethlisberger thinks he's the MVP so
Ben is right there and rightfully so Ben
should have been the MVP I agree so Ben
is right there smiling and I have to
yell and it's an confetti it's crazy
name it's bringing up the trophy I'm
going who's the MVP who's the MVP
finally I hear somebody say
and I don't know if they're saying
what's up homes they're saying homes and
I go I guess Antonio homes is the MVP so
we get up there and I Ben thinks he's
gonna move in for the kill and be the
MVP did you have to break the news to
him I sort of in a weird way like Ben
was like right here ready to come in and
the MVP is Santonio Holmes oh my god it
shouldn't be this difficult so I had I
had that the Eagles when they won last
year Kevin Hart is trying to get up on
the book remember that he was
over-served yes he was I'm I can hear it
so I'm I'm hearing him you know his
voice and I'm going who needs to be up
here and then I see that's Kevin Hart
and they he's ready to fight somebody
but I have since talked to Kevin a month
ago and I said you know what were you
doing and goes ah I was over-served an O
[Laughter]
I said what were you gonna do when you
got up there he goes I don't know I
don't know but I had to get up there did
you imagine all that it happened no I
mean that would have been I would have
had a very religious nick foles up there
and Kevin Hart probably dropping f-bombs
congratulations you bleep and bleep er
and you know you know it sounds like a
buddy-buddy you know road trip cop movie
yeah Nick Foles and Kevin Hart oh but
there's always an awkward moment because
you're when the Patriots won I meant I
meant I'm handed out the trophy though
was when they they beats you up so I'm
at the goalpost I'm right underneath the
goal posts because I think Seattle's
winning and I have to be ready to go out
there's about a seven minute window to
set up everything and get ready for the
ceremony and I'm I'm watching this
unfold and it goes in slow motion
because I'm thinking here comes beast
mode right right here's a touchdown
right here
so I watch to see if he's getting the
ball and then he doesn't and then I see
Russell Wilson go back to pass and I go
oh bleep and then I don't know if
Malcolm Butler's made the interception
right I just think he knocked it down
and then I go oh my god got it and then
you start in your mind going okay uh MVP
it Brady Brady is but it should be
Malcom Butler wait would they give it to
Malcolm Butler he just made the greatest
play in Super Bowl history a pillow
check is gonna be up there what do I ask
Belichick craps gonna be up there Oh
grunts so I start doing that formulating
that in my mind now the Patriots still
have the ball at the like the two yard
line right and then there's a fight that
breaks out by I think Bruce Irvin and
Gronk in the end zone like it's chaos
game ends up on the podium and I was
going to say to Brady you're the MVP are
you gonna let Malcom Butler drive your
truck
like I wanted to do it in a way for him
to come off as acknowledging Malcolm
Butler just won you your Super Bowl yeah
you're the MVP Malcolm Butler you know
should have been and I thought no yeah I
didn't want to get queued up there you
know because you got to be careful when
you're asking that in front of a couple
you know million people and I didn't but
I wanted him to say something to all of
the other one was Eli won a Corvette for
MVP but that's not his car right exactly
he is I believe a Toyota guy he's a
different brand so we're up there on the
podium you just beat the Patriots and I
have to read a card that says and
congratulations
fill in the name li Manning you are the
MVP and the proud owner of this
beautiful black on black Chevy Corvette
you know I have the keys I get done
reading I turn around
Eli's not there went down the steps and
I have to yell like I'd to go here's
your damn keys he didn't want to be seen
with Chevrolet keys and I'm giving you a
damn Corvette and I'm going like you
just you get done you go you got it well
you know that you know the Mannings I
mean Peyton dropped
his brand of beer yeah and his final
podium his career you know one Super
Bowl 50 you know how they worked but Eli
not as good at product placement but the
fact that you didn't want the keys and
he does have that Corvette I think at a
home in Mississippi
it's a sources club I tracked down that
damn thing I'm like but I did I wanted
to find out where that Corvette was but
the fact that you're up there in front
of know once against a hundred million
people right and they only remember if
you screw up never if you do it well
like they'll go oh you do know you
handed out the trophy yeah oh but if I
screwed of course it's like offensive
line you're you're only noticed if
you're called for holding I did ask
Gronk I said did you ever think that you
would have this feeling again he goes
well this is my first Super Bowl I won I
went I remember that all righty all
righty want to get away oh yeah you
can't that's all I thought about when I
got down off the podium I'm like how do
you get just you're gonna kick yourself
forever in that and you know you've got
a million shows before I let you go DP
who wins this one what do you think I'd
never go against Brady I just I've
learned it Brady and Belichick and I
don't root you know because people are
say who you're rooting for give me a
great story this is a great Super Bowl
and the Rams win in the final second you
know with like a phantom no call pass
interference or something like that
[Laughter]
like if the Rams win great and the
official who doesn't make the call was a
USC graduate has been born and raised in
Los Angeles it's rightly @dp show on
Twitter Dan Patrick show on Instagram
check out a new season of undeniable
with Dan his first season as the host
kicking off this January 30th at 8:00
p.m. Eastern and Pacific Dan you're the
man thanks buddy that's a charge himself
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on odd
yes